sie sollte politikerin werden sie wollte
holzschnitzeln werden und sie wurde
youtube in ihr wisst es alle darum steht
ja auch im jute und was sie in fünf
jahren vorhat ich sage nur zwei kinder
und so und noch viel mehr erfahrt ihr
jetzt im talk mit ihr viel spaß
ich bin überrascht dass du diese frage
stellt die lage ist sehr gut ich war
noch nie auf so einer bühne mit so einem
publikum aber ich bin gespannt wie es
wird und deswegen so ein bisschen
aufgeregt aber grundsätzlich gut okay du
bist jetzt aus berlin gekommen heute
morgen mit suchflugzeug flugzeug klug
war super erbetteln
und um das zu erklären du machst auf
youtube das was eine rubrik ist die dort
erst groß geworden ist du sitzt von der
kamera und erzählt wie man sich schön
macht oder
gut kleidet oder also wenn man es so
grundsätzlich verpacken wir dann ist es
dass auf jeden fall mode make up
lifestyle ich mache aber auch koch
videos oder einfach mal unsinn ist oben
immer mal wieder irgendwelche challenges
auf youtube brummen die man damit machen
kann und aber grundsätzlich ja schon das
beauty fashion related zeug genannt das
nennt man google das nennt man so ja
sind deine verhalten sich deine
zuschauer auch ihr gegenüber als wärst
du einen weiten bogen ich weiß noch
nicht wie sich guru zuschauer verhalten
es heißt nun mal leider so aber ja nein
nein nein okay aber du bist unglaublich
populär geworden dadurch
knapp drei millionen videoabrufe im
monat wie sah das vor einem jahr aus das
war nicht meine millionen glaube ich
also das ist wirklich dass es dieser
youtube einstieg ganz langsam
entschuldigung nein dass
ich meine im vergleich zu den drei
millionen dieser anstieg ist immer ganz
langsam und dann geht es über sich hoch
wie möglich mit wahnhaften angefangen
ich habe im oktober
2010 angefangen anderthalb jahre sind es
jetzt ein bisschen länger ja eine steile
karriere hast du das auch so empfunden
nein nein weil das ist ja nicht
realistisch für dich das ist ja immer
das gleiche was youtuber sagen weißt
immer das feedback schriftlich aber du
hast nie diese massen an menschen vor
dir deswegen ist es immer ganz schwierig
das zu realisieren das heißt es passiert
dennoch nicht dass auf der straße
angesprochen doch immer mehr ja ja aber
es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich nicht
mehr raus gehen kann oder so sachen es
ist wirklich noch ich weiß wenn ich im
alexa in berlin bin dass ich danach
bestimmt einen kommentar habe 2
kommentare ich hab dich gesehen oder
dass mich jemand anspricht okay aber das
ist nicht immer der fall ok also damit
angefangen hast hat sich das für sich
schon angekündigt oder war das ein
großer plan oder brahms gemacht nach dem
motto ach komm ich mach das mal für mich
also ich hab diese sparte entdeckt auf
youtube und herbst gesehen mit schminken
sich vor der kamera und ich war so was
das ist das aber irgendwie war es dann
so ok maximal was die wieder macht und
guckst du mal was die wieder macht und
dann dachte ich könnte c't du das auch
und dann hatte ich eine kamera und habe
es ausprobiert aber das war das ist
wirklich man sagt das immer so aber dass
du tausend abonnenten erreicht ist ein
traum gewesen hätte ich nicht gedacht
wie schnell gegen das 1000 ja vielleicht
zwei monate zweieinhalb ich weiß es
nicht also der anfang geht schon schwer
ja hat man das gefühl dann auch ich höre
auf oder redet man so angespannt nee ich
hab ja wie gesagt nicht mit dem plan
angefangen ist das groß werden soll und
es hat spaß gemacht und von daher ist es
auch immer besser geworden mit der zeit
und so ist es immer noch eigentlich von
der entwicklung her solltest du nicht
mal irgend einen richtigen beruf lernen
kommt die frage von meiner eltern
ja könnte ich machen aber ich glaube ich
bin jemand der immer auf zwei beiden
landet und bin sowieso eher so
quereinsteiger mäßig 1 geld und ich
glaube ich lande schon irgendwo okay das
war doch mal was gedacht ja
mehrmals also ich wollte als ich klein
war holzschnitzereien werden weil ich
mich aus lönneberga geguckt habe dann
fand ich sängerin ganz toll schauspiel
und immer so ein bisschen schon in die
außer holzschnitzer jetzt in die
publikums richtung ok und deine eltern
haben nie weil du gesagt hast kamen die
frage jetzt sollen eltern in richtung
ist einmal industriekauffrau
bankkauffrau
hotelfachfrau ich sollte politikerin
werden wie bitte politikerin das könnte
ich bestimmt hervorragend am ball dran
geglaubt ja mein papa möchte gerne immer
noch dass ich politikerin werde ist der
politik und heißt er nicht aber das ist
so ein versäumter traum von ihm und dann
so tennis mutter politiker vater
sozusagen und ja das wäre meine berufung
ok und deine mutter was hatte die
vorstellung ich weiß gar nicht die hat
mich immer in der moderation gesehen
komischer weil sie meinten ja so wie
nazan eckes bei exclusiv oder sowas und
das war so ihr traum denn deine eltern
aus der richtung oder war übernommen
kann man das übliche bei eltern ist ja
mach was vernünftig das hört sich alles
ziemlich unvernünftig jung aber wie man
mir wahrscheinlich auch ansieht ist es
jetzt nicht unbedingt komplett deutsche
familie und verschiedene kulturen und da
war nie so dieses klischee denken
irgendwie da vernünftig war immer da
aber vernünftig kann man ja verschiedene
auslegen okay aus welchem kulturen
kombat einmal aus dem raum asien- und
einmal europa ok und das hat sich
positiv
aus nicht auf dich ausgestellt ist das
super also da sind auch die kultur die
religion und ich bin ganz froh dass ich
auch hier leben darf und dass sich das
von beiden seiten mit bekommen darf und
ich glaube ich bin da ganz offen für für
die verschiedenen richtungen lässt du
das in deine videos einfließen
unbewusst vielleicht aber das ist nicht
so dass ich da jetzt irgendwie drauf
trimmer es ist halt toleranz allgemein
und ja das kommt bestimmt mal durch aber
hätten nicht so richtig ok wobei du hast
auch videos gemacht und dem aktuellen
thema coni 2012 ja aber das ist eher
weiligmann wird sich mit der zeit
bewusst dass da wirklich leute sitzen
die das mögen was du machst und die dir
zu hören und wenn du da so ein bisschen
einfluss drauf haben kannst auch so
wichtige themen denn es ist cool und
dann nutze ich das auch gerne bisschen
war das schon immer bei dir so dass sie
politisch engagiert was also nicht nur
aufoktroyiert durch deine eltern ich
würde das jetzt nicht als politisch
engagiert gezeigt nein weil ich nicht
ich habe null dafür interessiert so ein
video hat ja eine unglaubliche wirkung
du erreichst der wissel zuschauer hast
du pro video im schnitt 70.000 okay also
man muss sagen ich lade jeden tag ein
video hoch da ist das halt das ist schon
ganz gut glaube ich man 70 60 70.000 so
im schnitt würde ich sagen okay aber und
wie reagieren die dann auf sowas auch
aus der außer der reihe große ich
versuche so was immer richtig gut zu
recherchieren weil es echt schwierig ist
zu solchen themen irgendwas zu sagen
wenn du nur halbe informative wissen
hält gefährliches halbwissen und es gibt
immer welche die findest dann toll dass
du es machst es gibt aber genauso welche
die sagen ja das hättest du aber noch
besser recherchieren können und
grundsätzlich ist aber immer positiv
dass man diese reichweite nutzt
sozusagen ein journalist hat das ja
gelernt du hast das nicht gelernt das
ist ja auch immer der vorwurf hast du es
dir angeschafft oder was waren die
vorwürfe hast du wirklich recherche
fehler gemacht oder er hat fast schon so
gründlich dass du
sagen würdest das war schon okay ich
glaube das war schon okay ihr wenn dann
habe ich nicht zweites gesagt sondern er
vielleicht ich hätte noch etwas dazu
sagen können was vielleicht noch
ausschlaggebend gewesen wäre für die
meinungsbildung der leute sozusagen aber
das war jetzt nicht gravierend oder so
was meinst du dadurch ändert sich der
journalismus durch diese möglichkeiten
die eben jetzt auch neueinsteiger her
ich glaube da ist auch das wort
authentisch wieder ganz wichtig weil ich
recherchiere das für mich das heißt für
die leute sie können das genauso
recherchieren und müssen es nicht
gelernt haben oder sonstwas und können
sich dadurch eine meinung bilden also
ich glaube schon dass es da neue
möglichkeiten und offenere einstellungen
zum gibt wobei man ja auch sagen muss
das fällt mir dann immer auch selbst
nachrichtenagenturen machen nach dem
klavier gravieren das stimmt aber das
würde sich auf youtube auch noch ein
bisschen krasser auswirken wenn man da
einen fehler macht würde man da glaube
ich echt geflecht das stimmt ab da als
ein beispiel da hat sich ja auch auf
youtube wirklich eine
riesengaudi bildet das ist doch top star
rahma war weil ich glaube es gab so eine
anmeldeseite auch für die aktuellste und
es ist schon vorher durchs netz gegangen
aber als dann auf youtube und zwar unter
youtube an verabredet es losging hat
sich die bewegung vervielfacht was
ändert sich dadurch was ändert sich
durch social media in der politik die
reichweite allgemeines interesse mit der
authenzität schweres wort achtung immer
falsch authentizität für die cdu sehr
gut der menschen du erreichst viel mehr
als wenn du siehst hier zdf geht man zur
demo oder so du kannst sagen ich würde
mich echt freuen zusätzlich hast du
natürlich immer dass dass sich leute
auch mal treffen wollen das ist so ein
kleines nebenbei so beide way kannst du
den dann auch sehen dich mit dem
unterhalten und so und das zieht einfach
viel mehr
daraus gefragt hast du das gefühl wir
distanzieren uns durch diese medien
immer mehr wir am rechner sitzen und nur
über youtube kommentare über tweets über
facebook kommentare kontakt zueinander
haben oder ist genau das gegenteil der
fall wie bei acta wo sie ja dann alle
auf die straße gegangen ich glaube das
ergänzt sich ganz gut von beiden seiten
so zu sagen und ich glaube nicht dass
man sich davon also wenn man sich davon
entfernen will tut man das ansonsten ist
das glaube ich eine gute ergänzung dazu
hat sich das leben verändert durchs netz
auch dein leben weil ich meine auch
während meiner pubertät hat sich das ja
langsam diese richtung komplett ja also
ich kann es dir nicht nur beschreiben
aber
es ist ganz anders die möglichkeiten die
sachen die man machen darf machen kann
machen soll ist einfach toll davis also
könntest du das noch ohne vorstellen
nein also ich denke dass es endlich
irgendwann wahrscheinlich sehr schöne
nicht aber ich glaube es ist endlich
aber ich will es mir nicht vorstellen
gut apropos endlich
wunderbare frage aus dem
bewerbungsgespräch immer wieder gerne
gestellt wo siehst du dich in fünf
jahren
da habe ich eine weltreise gemacht und
habe zwei kinder und ein mann in fünf
jahren schon eher unten läuft in berlin
okay
die frage was ich mir zehn jahren wurde
da wären wir wieder beim anderen thema
wo alle immer heiß darüber diskutieren
kann man von youtube leben ja kann man
also muss man sich erarbeiten aber ich
denke auf lange sicht können das kann
das können dass viele schaffen auf jeden
fall das heißt was siehst du die zukunft
weil man mal sagen du hast jetzt gesagt
wo siehst du dich privat wo siehst du
youtube in fünf jahren war das ist so
schwierig das ist auch mit dem fernseh
thema wie weit wird fernsehen noch gehen
und so ich sehe mich auf meinem kanal
glaube ich weil das das habe ich
angefangen das habe ich mir aufgebaut
und dann vielleicht breiter gefächert
noch in andere richtungen mal ein
größeres projekt was man komplett
durchziehen kann oder so und einfach die
möglichkeiten nehmen die einem da durch
gegeben werden so das will ich gern
nutzen hat sich ein wunschtraum für dich
da durch die youtube erfüllt ja ich bin
glücklich ich bin gerade wirklich
absolut glücklich mit der situation wie
sie ist und das kann auch vorbei gehen
aber es ist gerade ist das super und ich
glaube das ist ganz viel wert magst du
dich manchmal sogar dem motto ist es war
nie so wichtige aktion mache ich nicht
aber ich denke es manchmal
dann hoffe ich dass das noch lange
denken ja vielen dank dass sie gerne
und es gibt noch mehr talk auf klicks um
zb den mit den außenseitern die sagen es
ist wie eine krankheit was wieso weshalb
warum im talk mit den beiden oder der
mit hasuobs einem der erfolgreichsten
gamer in deutschland der darüber redet
wenn gaming das leben finanziert also
eins von beiden könnte anklicken
ansonsten gestand bleibt dran